to call the legend zelda breath of the
wild a big game is a bit of an
understatement it's so chock-full of
surprises and mysteries that you could
play for weeks on end and still miss a
ton of fun stuff but if you're a little
pressed for time exploring every nook
and cranny in Hyrule don't worry we've
got you we've compiled some of the best
Easter eggs the game manages to sneak
into its world now if you're more of a
homebody and hunting for secrets isn't
quite your thing you can check out our
cooking guide or our video on how to
make money instead but if adventure is
in your heart let's go find some secret
stuff Easter eggs might be hint all over
the map or maybe they're closer than you
think in fact if you pull out your scope
and mark a location in the distance
you'll see the marker extend to the sky
there is some text written in the shaft
of light which says this now these
characters are all over the game and you
might brush them off at first but the
game's alphabet has actually been
decoded meaning that this text actually
reads it's dangerous to go alone a
reference to the moment you get the
sword in the very first Zelda game well
what are you waiting for let's get
moving
traveling between all the locations in
the game can get pretty tiring good
thing you have your horse right the wind
in your hair some nice music playing hey
wait a second let's speed that music up
a bit no you're not imagining things
that is actually Zelda's Lullaby you're
hearing and if you head on over to the
temple of time and speed that music up
well you might hear another familiar
tune
[Music]
yes the music in Zelda is great and
hidden tracks like these make coming
back to certain parts of the game all
the more rewarding and while we're
looking at ties to ocarina of time
here's another one we know that Hyrule
has been severely messed up thanks to
Ganon but the casualties of the calamity
aren't always that obvious if you
venture into Hyrule Field you'll come
across what the map calls ranch ruins
but if you take a closer look it's not
just any old ranch if the entrance
Fallen tower and racetrack seem familiar
that's because this used to be long long
ranch while its residents are long gone
and you won't run into Talon Mallon or
ingo anywhere in the game
EEP when the still lives on albeit in
amiibo form that's good enough for me
and speaking of residents of our
presidents there is a traveler you can
meet that bears a striking resemblance
to Nintendo's late former president
Satoru Iwata his name is bot Rick a
watchman who can be found wandering
around the outskirts stable just north
of the great plateau if you talk to him
he'll give you some advice on nearby
environments and monsters as well as
sell you some equipment for your travels
maybe it's the prominent split in the
hair or maybe it's the glasses affixed
to his face or perhaps it's the warm
welcoming demeanor of the character that
reminds me of owada
regardless but Rick is a gentle soul
diligently fulfilling his duties as a
stables watchman if you pester him
enough he'll tell you about the Lord of
the mountain a mythical being atop
Satori Mountain and if you travel to
that location you'll find a cherry
blossom tree overlooking a small serene
pond but come here at just the right
time and you might actually catch a
glimpse of that lower the mountain he
was talking about
[Music]
so what do you think of these Easter
eggs do you think they're legitimate or
are we grasping at straws here and are
there any that we should include in
another video let's talk about them in
the comments below and consider
subscribing to the GameSpot YouTube
channel for even more zelda breath of
the wild coverage